hello everyone i think this is the third
week in aurora where you are hearing
from future alana
i am not in this episode because i'm in
a country where the internet isn't fast
enough for me to maintain a zoom call
i haven't been able to do any of my work
video meetings or anything
but related to that because i am
currently unable to
record the podcast uh we will also be
skipping the next
two weeks um it kind of depends when i'm
allowed back in la but for now i'm
pretty sure the next episode of the
podcast will release on the 20th
i just decided to give everybody a break
um since i can't produce it right now so
why not just give the boys two weeks off
so
there is this episode of course and then
we will not have episodes for
the 6th and the 13th and if that gets
any later i will let you all know
if you want updates in more real time
you can follow pwl underscore podcast on
twitter
and instagram otherwise enjoy the
episode let's get doing the lana now
yeah she's represented look at you with
the undercut
you like that it's a little scruffy at
the moment yeah
yeah and you're drinking a coffee
i'm not i'm secretly drinking pepsi from
a coffee mug
so now that's just that's that's
mentally misleading
that's misleading that's that's it's
been a tough couple of days but i don't
want to necessarily talk about it so i'm
putting on the front of a mug it's
actually i had a big bowl of pepsi
is it because you're like it's just like
takeaway delivers balls of pepsi that's
all it was
just like the guy comes to your door and
he brings you a single pepsi and a
single pepsi
you can see a hug just hollow awkwardly
for maybe
too long and you're like oh that's gary
that's enough
right sorry mark i have a bad time mate
i don't know why i'm where's he from
he's from the eastern you know so he
goes up i'm from eastern it
yeah do you know me i'll give you a
cuddle
because you feel like you're a big man
that needs a cow
so it's beautiful i'm awesome i need to
be here for this
this is powerful stuff it's powerful
stuff
and it is inside the actor's studio with
uh
jesus uh yeah no no
no offense intended about the
wonderfully
graciously provided microphone i'm
horrifically offended and hexagonal
panels
um they're really cool
yeah they're really cool i put those up
on my uh there was a hospital
yeah there was a whole sort of delivery
uh it's very very nice very very this is
the best okay so miguel lozado
shout out to my boy and here's the
beauty of it when when i first i became
friends with him and i was like hey man
what do you need for mrs like nothing
dude we don't we don't need your help
they're doing fine
uh he's like yeah man just just use it
and enjoy it and if you like it and you
know tell people but we're good
so i said hey man can you can you hook
my peeps up with some mics he's like
sure and he always goes above and beyond
so like he's just a just a good dude so
there you go
but you didn't plug it in so you're a
dick well yeah it just shows that
he's a better person i guess than than i
am or either of us are
all right wait what yeah you're gonna
you're gonna wait until you're in the
new digs right i've got i've got my
floor now
in my office i've got the skirting
boards going in tomorrow and then i can
finally put the desk in and start
actually building out
the office the way i want it so i'm
excited does that mean by
the next recording of this show
it'll be the one after be the one after
we'll be i'll be over there
so yeah quite
are you next like out of this place
we're just like period like outlook when
you're gonna grow up
in general what am i gonna get out of
this rut no i'd like you
the the piano was that if was that a
product of of
so the piano it was you just you didn't
want to go
two feet over this way you're like and
turn around i
i had a i had it where my
pc that has like my
gaming rig and stuff was over here
right um and the the computer is
like in the desk and the piano is
against that wall
and then what happened was two things
i guess three things all kind of fed off
of each other
first new computer which is currently
basically just sitting next to the
computer and all the old equipment is
just sitting here lifelessly
so it's occupying space that required
moving the gaming pc over to here
because
the the current rig is you know i needed
to put it somewhere
so then the piano just got kind of
pushed farther away then uh
in the middle of the pandemic i had to
do i did this
um collaboration with 10 cent
for their pub g uh
their pub g sort of
re like it's not a remake it's
like a licensed something i guess it's
the
pub g or is it is it like it's our pubg
killer kind of thing no no it's pub g
it's just they had to rename it due to
chinese censorship
boards um because uh
battleground was a was a uh you know um
was a sufficiently violent title so
uh so the the overlords uh in china made
it them change the name to game for
peace
they asked me and brian tyler to do the
music called games in peace
it's called game of thrones
can you can you even believe that fluffy
and the fact that that actually works
the stupidity of that strategy
actually works like they they did it
purely to evade
the sensors and the fact that it works
is
just hilarious so um so yes
the um but 10 cent were very keen
it was it was actually it was actually
really great um
process we were able to record it all in
vienna they were like the only orchestra
that basically was operating in
in covid um they had a sufficiently
large studio and we had to cap the size
of the group and stuff so we did a
remote we were gonna
do it in l.a we actually had a date on
the books at fox it would have been the
first
union la game recording that i
do since 2012 and but they had to pull
out because the la county
covid measures were such a moving target
that they were like
yeah we this could get cancelled the
night before and and it's non-refundable
you know like the musicians union has a
has a thing that if the musician takes a
job and you're within a few days of the
session
you're paying them regardless of what
you do even if you reschedule it you're
still paying for that date it's just a
it's just
it's a requirement of the union so they
realize but it's
from a producer standpoint that's highly
highly
volatile yeah absolutely i do think it's
fair
in general but situations like oh well
the health department made it so that
literally no one's working
you're not like that would seem like a
reasonable exception to wave the rule
because
that musician it's not like they're
turning down another job
that they could have then done all jobs
were done
now of course you could then make the
argument that well on account of all
jobs being done
you know they've just lost work too but
i would say but it's
it's money being spent that's that's
yielded no return of any kind
you know we may as well just paypal them
the money to stay at home
uh at that point so the the uh the
producers very uh understandably said
let's try for vienna
and um uh and they did a phenomenal job
and so they wanted to produce a
behind-the-scenes video and the guy that
came over the studio to film it
was like oh it'd be so cool if we kind
of build this little alcove where you're
you know it's like your desk sort of if
you were to go up above me it forms kind
of this v
where i'm like i got my computer here
and the piano behind me and they kind of
converge in that corner and so they set
up all their lighting and shot it and it
actually looked pretty cool
and then the first time we did this show
where i realized i could just lean back
and do this which i never had the luxury
of before
combined with the fact that i haven't
had it because i have a couch on the
other side of this
that normally you know i would have
meetings on you've both sat on that
couch
uh the uh the the lack of meetings for
the last
year and a half made me realize i don't
actually care that i'm blocking the
couch
this is not really a there's not really
a social environment anymore unless i'm
talking to my screen so i just figured
held it and i i
left the piano there that's the
definitive peter jackson cut
answer to your question no [ __ ] that was
like the criterion answer
it was yep and also a lot like a lot to
do for a film crew i did i have to tell
you
i'll tell you guys it was such a funny
thing did i tell you about the time that
like
a film crew built like a fake apartment
for me for making off did i tell you
about this
it was amazing you're thinking green
screen that [ __ ]
no fake this is all yeah exactly this is
the illusion well they um
they built they wanted to shoot it in
new york and obviously i don't live in
new york
so they just got they they like put
their friends cast in the background
like they literally i guess they rented
an apartment or it was like someone's
friend's apartment that
looked similar to this place so similar
like
i mean boring apartment the exact same
color walls in every other apartment
internationally right
but like they they put in bookshelves
which they then
went to like uh secondhand bookshops and
found nerdy books to put on the shelves
because that was like
genuine i'm not gonna say because i want
to drop anyone in it but it was just a
weird kind of i showed up and it was
like
it was like walking into like a truman
show version of my
real apartment i was like this is the
weirdest thing and then they were like
uh at the end of the day they were like
oh by the way we bought all these books
just as
a set dressing no one no one wants these
these
nonsense kind of because this is the
beginning of your library well i i
the the irony was that none of the books
they bought were things i want so i
didn't i had
an option of taking all these free books
that were like meant to be mike biffle
books i didn't want any of them and it
was just a weird kind of
thing whatever in my life no stage in my
career have i ever been
that important what's a what's a nerdy
what's a nerdy book that you wouldn't
want
you remember it's just well it was it
was the comic presumably i think what
they've done is they'd sent a runner to
like i know the local comic book store
and like gone into like because it's
just set dressing gone into like
the reject spin in the comic store so it
was like
a bunch of like comics you've never
heard of and like
like the bubble gum man stuff like it
was just
it's a lot of trash basically and like
and all like um
like mugs in the shape of like various
superheroes heads and stuff
and all this thing it's like i'm not
nerdy no they're always just like
standing against that wall okay
so i'm just gonna give an interview or
or get
whacked one of the two if i ever walk
into a room and there's like white
linoleum i'm like joe pesci and
goodfellas i'm like oh no
if i'm ever if i'm ever waxed i wanted
to be in a full replica of my own home
not my own home and then your last
thought would be like those [ __ ]
books
pow yeah it's a replica with those
comics
it was like walking into a cool guy's
criticism of me as a human being like i
was like
what a cool guy like like a cool guy
you're into this right
he's like this stuff you like this stuff
this is you is it this is this is how
you live right
yes i like all of these things very much
thank you
that is excessive that is that i thought
i thought my
i thought my elaborate behind the scenes
production was
was um was over the top
but this this is what you're talking
about is a whole other level
they did although i will say here's the
one way that they did beat you for this
because brian tyler was involved in this
project of you know
a hollywood uh you know marvel acclaim
and many other
fast and the furious films and all that
kind of thing brother of the lead singer
of aerosmith
they really like wrong
wrong uh wrong aerosmith tie-in uh from
the video game industry the correct
answer is tommy talarico
uh who is in fact cousins of stephen
tyler because stephen tyler's birth last
name is talarico
for real um that's a hollywood name
change
that explains so much about tommy to me
now oh absolutely yes
uh tommy steven tyler has actually come
to video games live shows it
on occasion like before my time
but yeah so because because 10 cent was
obviously very keen
to highlight brian's involvement and
again understandably
they were really disappointed when we
weren't going to be recording the score
in la where we would both be personally
conducting the orchestra and so what
they decided to do
again purely for the behind the scenes
video because this had no
actual practical function but which made
for fun filmmaking
was they booked the entire fox scoring
stage that we would have been on where
you could easily fit 105 piece orchestra
and brian went in there and conducted
alone
and then they projected the footage of
him conducting to the orchestra in
vienna
on a huge monitor over their shoulders
so that you like
see them playing the music while he's
conducting it but he was
tracked in l.a so they had to they had
to book the fox lot
at the fox scoring stage to do that
which did they did they show him from
behind so
he was clearly in an empty room or did
they just like well the camera and
vienna
was like facing him like
you know conductor cam so it's the same
pov although closer
than uh the musicians are getting but
obviously for the behind the scenes you
can clearly see it's a giant empty room
just to show like hey we're having fun
we're making it work
it was actually a fun idea as a way to
roll with the punches
uh you know i find it interesting though
that you you said
you could easily fit 105. like that felt
like an arbitrary
integer to add on to an article that's
just the largest group that i know
that's the largest that i've been in the
room with so i know that it's at least
that much
everything's stolen weird numbers like
okay guys guys guys no
you fifth tuba go home 106
is just obscene well funny enough you do
reach a point where you
you physically he sounds like a tuba
that you've already
had to play the tuba well it'd be weird
if he was like i play the tuba
like your forefoot the instrument's
larger than you are
hey man it's all it's all possible
that's like my favorite
harpist uh among the many
favorite harpists in london hugh webb
uh is a he guy looks like uh he looks
like cast from
sons of anarchy and he's like the top
call harpist in london huge handlebar
mustache and
he just dwarf like the harp is dwarfed
by him like he's just this huge guy
the [ __ ] out of this thing and he does
he's that's the funny thing he's a
[ __ ] badass harpist like he's so good
um that's cool and uh but he if you just
saw him on the street you'd think he was
someone's
you know s like protection like their
their their
uh their escort uh michael chiklis in
uh uh high fidelity where he's the big
bully but
he wrote he wrote a poem yeah basically
yes
exactly that i think that was the
inspiration for the guy becoming a
harpist it was
but yeah this isn't the case this is
weird because this is this is what
happens when we're unsupervised it's
just
what a lack of video game topic hey
we're talking about game for peace
we are we've we're blowing the doors off
of the lies in uh behind the scenes
uh filmmaking so that's good that's good
we're exposing
the dishonesty ironically to most people
i i would think that they're like
alana's probably getting
just as much uh microphone time as
she would if she were present because
it's just like
rare just hurting us in a single
direction so anyway
what actually happened in the world
today i was like but
um is there anything you guys had that
interesting happen i'm trying to think
well it's funny because mike you just
prompted a thought where i'm trying to
think if there was ever
a behind the scenes that explicitly
misled like it's one thing to yeah it's
one thing
this is fine yeah and it's another to
kind of make it seem like
you know i think the only one that i can
think of as an example and i and i
i'm sure i've told this story at least
to troy but i've probably told it on
this show
but i remember on the signs dvd the m
night shyamalan movie
they have a little feature at about the
score or maybe it's where they have like
they have they have a full documentary i
think maybe about the behind the scenes
that
zeroes in on the music proportion of no
i think it's a standalone feature you
could probably find it on youtube
and the score of that movie is
unbelievably excellent like
like james newton howard did such
wonders for all of those movies with m
night shyamalan
um and signs is in many ways it's a tie
i think between signs in the village of
which has the best score because they're
both like they're both up there
tie between yeah i'm on oh we're on the
edge of our seats
we've lost austin which is great because
he's recording oh there he is oh you're
back yeah it's weird you both
you both froze for a second now it's
what it says your internet connection
you froze
this is this is something this is
something you okay it was it's a tie
between what
village and science uh uh in terms of
best score for an inmate shyamalan film
um i would say personally and so
signs they recorded it all at todd ayo
studio that no longer exists
a huge orchestra and there's this
footage of them recording and
james is not a conductor so he's in the
booth pete anthony's
who's orchestrator also uh conducting
and m knight is sitting with him at the
at the console and um
he goes um they did like a take and it
had some issues as happens sometimes
especially complicated
horror sci-fi music and so james says
like oh no they'll get it it'll be
it'll be fine uh we'll just take it
again and uh shyamalan goes um
they just need to give it 10 more love
and he's like well
they really just need to read it again
like it's it's not that there's
something written
shyamalan's like just just just tell him
10
more love and he's like i promise just
just let him play it again it'll be fine
you know it's like trying to run the
session and not let it be derailed
basically
and they keep coming back to this moment
and the way it's cut it looks like
oh the camaraderie director composer
and so like it's kind of like they use
this whole 10
more love thing as a recurring motif
keep cutting back to that and then
they'll cut to like talking head b-roll
where he's describing oh you know here's
how i think about music in my movie and
blah blah blah blah and so it's like a
whole feature
at about scoring but they'll keep going
back to this one moment during the
sessions and then the very last bit the
kind of button on the end of the
featurette
is him going um shyamalan
almost frustrated going you know if you
just said ten percent more love it would
solve all this and so james picks up the
little talkback
um remote control so that the orchestra
can hear him
and he just goes the note
is ten percent more love
and he has this face like [ __ ] god
and
and m knight is like haha i love it and
and if you i've never watched anything
about
recording you would look at that and
smile and laugh and because
you're getting the m night shyamalan
perspective
so well captured but if you know
anything about music you look at james's
face it's like
my god get me out of this um it's so
funny his agony where it really is
it is portraying a moment the exact
opposite of the way it's being felt by
the people there
and you know i i want
what's your i want song
i really am this is this has been my
struggle lately is that
i and i think you and i talked about
this austin um but
i had a tendency to make a blanket
indictment of someone's character that
forever branded them
i think that's the whole that's everyone
right that's first that's
the whole notion of first impressions
yeah i think that that is sure
but this may not even be a first
impression this this could be
um i just
thought this person was this way um
and then i would try to rope people into
i mean you know they're an [ __ ] right
right like getting that agreement that
consensus on it yeah which is
completely probably unfounded it's
uninformed and it's
and i just forgot high school right as
well like it's very for sure
but what i want to do is i want to get
to the place where it's like
i don't know i haven't seen them today
today could be the day that
they decided to turn it all around today
could be the day that they woke up and
bent
man i'm an [ __ ] and i don't want to
be caught
on that day being wrong i would much
rather go i don't know
they were an [ __ ] that day but we
were talking about this today my in-laws
were in town
and we're talking about um you know bad
celebrity
interactions and i
i had one once at an airport and i had
just gotten off a bad phone call and
gotten some bad news and there were
people that maybe at the airport that
were wanting autographs and i
just i i just lit this guy up and
it was not good and it was not a good
moment for me
and i i really i i went back through the
the airport i i found him i was like hey
man
i'm really sorry like you caught me at a
bad moment and i wish i hadn't done that
i say all that is a setup too i want
to to believe that m knight shalom is
actually a good dude
and that is a good director but man
every story i hear
just proves that he's he's not
and i i don't know if that's my
interpretation of it i don't know if
people are like man you just don't know
and i don't want to be that person like
he's an [ __ ] he's like he's actually
the most kind
generous caring person but just i look
at that
regardless of if if it's you know giving
a note to the conductor to the orchestra
to the actors to your dp
to craft services it doesn't matter 10
more love
is just the most selfish form of
directing
i could possibly think of it's
non-actionable you can't what does that
mean to you
well especially more love it also
implies a lack of effort up to that
point right
it implies that the profession working
with hasn't been
working hard on it yeah you've only been
giving 90 percent i'm like [ __ ] you dude
like
austin i think about what you say about
horns about how horns will hold back
brass will hold back because
they've they physically their embouchure
will is that correct to say that
the embouchure will fail them after a
certain point so they're like we're
going to figure this out
the muscles just become fatigued like
the sheer amount of air pressure you
have to maintain on your lips to
to hold a seal and to to be able to
direct the airflow and hold a good
uh you know in keep the pitch in tune
good intonation
um is so exhausting after a while that
if they
if they are asked to just relentlessly
blast fortissimos at some point they're
gonna fall apart
so it's like just get one of these it's
like the big you know
the big screaming you know note or
whatever it's like
in every session like mikey doesn't
really go hey we got some yelling let's
do that towards the end
because like the dialogue is really
where we need to kind of find the
subtlety and the nuance everything else
is just like
scream as if you're on fire you know
right and there's no way to do that
there's some people that try to train
you and go
uh well you can use your diaphragm if
you open up your throws like all that
stuff is great but at the end of the day
you are still
forcing air out of your throat at a at a
high volume high decibel rate and it's
gonna it's gonna tear you up you just
can't do it
yeah um unless you're frank welker or
fred tatasha
or d bradley baker um so i i look at
that and i go
it's just ten percent more love i'd be
like how about you give ten percent more
effort and
actually come up with an actionable note
because i'm assuming that those
musicians are
they're showing up there they don't want
their performance to be bad so if
there's a good note to be had
give me the good note but don't well
then especially
you know again it's a selectively cut
thing but in the context of
you hear james say that was just a
reading take like they just need another
take like there's nothing
systemically wrong with their
performance there isn't like
a typo in the sheet music exactly like
they they
people forget when you're when you're
accustomed to
to you know routinely being in the
studio with
these top tier musicians you forget the
inherent wizardry of what they're doing
they are taking a piece of music that
has never been in front of them before
and they're playing it as if they've
been practicing it for months uh you
know
they are the fact that it's anything
short of
perfection in the first take is a thing
that should be it's like the louis ck
i'm in a chair in the sky
like it should be a thing that
completely dumbfounds everyone all the
time forever even if you're john
williams and you've stood in front of
those
people hundreds of times it's still
just an astonishing feat that it's even
possible to do especially on a
you listen to the score of the signs and
it is not
humdrum musically kind of pedestrian
it's it's it's freaking it's freaking
involved
and uh and the orchestra has real [ __ ]
to do
and so people are learning and playing
and playing with expression
and emotion and sensitivity you know
they're shaping it straight out of the
gate in the first try it is an
astonishing thing that
really not a lot of musicians in the
world can do in la and london
uh being two of the hubs of some of the
most talented people at this
in the world and so i wonder what that
looks like to someone like i'm not
shyamalan who
if you're like that was their first
basically their first draft and he's
like well that's what i shoot
so i don't know how much iteration he
gives to his movies and again
there's something oh no he he definitely
does loads like he definitely
those film those films are very
structurally
thought through i think for like don't
get me wrong i'm not saying every movie
he does is excellent but it seems like
it seems like i i don't think you could
accuse him of not putting thought into
it like it seems they all feel like
films have been through several drafts
to me
i think that's that laziness to it
they're often they're often misguided
like one of my genuinely unironically
one of my favorite films is the
village just because it's so so
misguided but
so uh aggressive in its intent it's a
bad idea executed with absolute passion
and that makes it fascinating to me well
he even says
on the documentary is like i wanted to
make an r-rated movie that was the whole
reason why i did this i want to make an
r
so we went for it whatever would give us
an r rating we did it i'm like
yeah that's that's very odd that reminds
me that's not like
that's not laziness to me that's
something else that's that's uh
misguided
it is misguided i think that's a better
characterization i think what all those
have in common
my monday morning i've never met him
i've never been around him i totally am
with you troy like i want
all of the assumptions that this starts
to add up to
about him to turn out to be this
mischaracterization that you know he's
just been
he's been victim to you know his own
sort of bad press or whatever uh i would
love for that to be true but it does
seem to me
from a from a sort of monday morning
quarterback kind of perspective
that he's not
being told no by people or at least in
the prior
now his movies are all kind of low
budget and apparently they're kind of
getting good again although i haven't
seen so i think in a lot of cases yeah
what's his latest movie i don't even
know well he did that he just came out
yeah that one i
i yeah that's brand new i haven't i
haven't seen i don't know anything about
it i did this we did split but people
said split
i did not see but people said split was
actually quite uh a
you know a return to form for him it's
fine it's fun mcavoy's having a good
time in it like you can def
it's i wouldn't say it's excellent but
it's it's good it's a good b movie
like you know what was it with james
mcavoy before he really popped where
it essentially was all taking place in
the second that someone died and he like
lived out this entire
life i don't remember that one i mean
that sounds like always interesting
because
that's basically the plot of jacob's
ladder sure
one of those actors who was on british
tv for like decades before like
like when do americans first like when
does mcavoy hit in america is it
it's not amazing it's before that isn't
wasn't he um
wasn't he oh he's like
he's yeah yeah yeah probably uh
chronicles of narnia
yeah would be the would be the first
thing or i think it's also possible
um
every every british actor who could put
on an army uniform
because it was all shot in the uk so
like if you go back brothers now
oh yeah everyone in that like if you
watch band of brothers now like
off to the side is um what's his name um
no tom hiddleston in that one he's in
one called conspiracy which is similarly
small kind of world war two oh you mean
uh
tv show you mean fast fender uh i might
be thinking
oh yeah michael fassbender was in it
and um oh god venom why am i getting the
same this
hearty tom hardy tom hardy's in it um
it's funny because a lot of the a lot of
that cast are good friends of mine
who because they all became like working
actors and i they basically
a bunch of low-budget films that they
were shifting you know as they all
started to hit their 40s
um they started shifting into more
writing and producing and i got hooked
in with one of those guys and then he
kind of passed me around
the group and i remember yeah you told
me about this that
that cast like those that group of guys
um are some of the nicest most
you know they're the perfect antidote to
the the
the cliche hollywood is full of a bunch
of [ __ ] like
you know a bunch of bullshitters who
will just say whatever to
and and and you know never be genuine
with you in it
to the last person of everyone i've
interacted with who was associated with
band of brothers that couldn't
possibly be farther from the truth like
these are people deeply committed to
their craft
they're people that are extremely
grateful for the opportunity because for
pretty much all of them it launched
their careers
sort of like that's got to have been a
hard shoot as well you'd have to be a
certain kind of person to do well in
that kind of
they were all young fast and out in the
cold right like it would
that would be a ridiculous project to
work on and consistently early on
and well considering that it's about a
bunch of world war ii
um uh you know draftees
these would all be people you know in
their early 20s
give or take and so they're they're
they're not that experienced
also uh by and large and yeah but
every one of them speaks with immense
amounts of reverence
and and love about spielberg and tom
hanks and just the thing and and for
years the best part
is that most of these guys they're all
portraying real people like band of
brothers is a true story
and for years for the veterans who were
still alive
they i think i think they're all gone
now maybe one or two is like pushing a
hundred but for years they did
they did events like world war ii you
know or normandy beach
anniversary kind of commemorations and
those sorts of things where they would
go and tour around with
the guy they portrayed and so they all
developed these really special
friendships with these you know 70 80 90
year old
world war ii like literal paratrooping
veterans who lived through this stuff
and they all
think that that was like one of the
greatest privileges that that supersedes
anything
that they could ever achieve as an actor
to be able to bond with these
these guys that by any that by any
metric you could imagine are like
actual heroes uh you know and you'd walk
past in the street if you saw them right
like you like you don't
know the book's fascinating actually if
anyone listening wants to
pick up the band of brother the book the
band of brothers i think i think
the version i read was called bandi
brothers i don't know if it was
originally called you know that has that
book behind it
i well i don't half my bookcase is gone
now so i see that it does look like in a
state of different diminishing
it's diminishing it's working its way
across cause we've got new because we've
got like
uh like our downstairs we've just got
like a rows of bookshelves because
i i have too many books so we're we're
trying to figure out just the right
amount don't let anyone tell you
otherwise
i there's a funny story a friend of mine
was
one of the mixers at um remote control
with hans zimmer and when they were
doing
the pacific they were doing a listen
back and
it was tom hanks steven spielberg hans
zimmer and satoshi who's the mixer
they're in the room and they're all just
sitting there because i knew that you
knew satoshi have we never talked about
do you know satoshi i mean i've met him
i don't know
me and the satoshi should we go right
back yeah yeah that guy's a wicked
wicked engineering mixer
but tom hanks is just kind of sitting
back and in his droll
beautiful humor and i think a lot of
people sometimes forget that he's one of
the funniest people
oh so funny yeah he just sits back just
everyone's just kind of waiting for them
to load up the new session or whatever
and tom hanks just goes
i just want to point out the irony that
we're watching a world war ii show
with a german a jew an american
and a japanese person he was like this
is the apex of harmony
this is what we can achieve it's so
interesting isn't it
good it's like i find it so fascinating
that
three of the most powerful economies and
strongest
like trade partners and general
alliances in the world today are the us
germany and japan like what a
fascinating
piece of historical perspective that is
money can bring us together mike you see
that it's beautiful
it's beautiful capitalism works that's
what i've always said
that's what i've always said well trade
you know it's
it's the uh it's the it's the it's the
age-old lesson that you know trade is a
lot
hell a lot more effective than bombs
um damn straight and um did you see on
the sub
tangentially related to japan did you
see that um
the opening olympic ceremony used a
bunch of jrpg music
uh uh as their music i i
i saw all my twitter feed exploding that
like the tokyo olympics opened with
music from
you know like chrono trigger and and uh
various
final fantasy yeah it was it was there
were some legitimate deep cuts in there
and well it's it's yeah that's that's
their that's one of their largest kind
of cultural exports right like
it's like mr bean being in the uh well
not mr b knock off mr bean being in them
because
technically that wasn't mr bean in the
in the british olympics opening ceremony
because it wasn't real now it was rowan
atkinson
playing a mr bean-like character for
playing they couldn't get the rights to
mr bean yeah exactly
lintel that guy is so talented man his
his scene in love actually where he's
preparing the thing for alan rickman
is like a short film of perfection you
know it's just well and also he's
playing
opposite alan rickman
i grew up dude on like the worst era of
your television so it was like are you
being served faulty towers to the men
are born
um that stuff's great
it is great stuff some of it's not aged
particularly well but now
this is good stuff has there that's like
way like people were like dude are you
watching doctor who i'm like
no because i grew up on like the
original
all right we got about 50 pound to make
this whole show
so what are we going to do i that was
never done gary was involved in that
most people don't know that but he's got
no knuckles he can't even be he's like
sausages
so he just flaps his he don't have no
knuckles though so he's just poles
yeah his two jobs were making doctor who
and delivering pepsi
this is that's all he does i loved you
by the way you're a brilliant
oh thank you so much it was a long time
ago but yeah
i don't do the tell anymore not
since the incident you know the funny
thing is that that's not
wildly unrealistic the uh you know the
song
uh mr postman the kind of
50s classic yeah yeah that was written
by a postman who's whose uh
like record like the record label that
i don't remember which uh he kind of
wrote that song and sort of dropped it
off in the mail as part of his route
and uh the way i learned that story is
that one time
i had to get some my internet went down
and they had to come do some some
physical stuff
on the wall like in the cabling uh and
the att
or whoever sent a guy and that postman
author of mr postman was this a t guy's
father
so we sat here for an hour i was like
you want a coffee and like let's just
talk
and like he said he was the son of the
guy who wrote it not he was the son of
it
how old were you 97 i wish i could
retire
yeah i think that that would have been a
cautionary tale in royalty negotiations
if that would have been like the guys
with the band of brothers guys it was
an opportunity for you to learn from the
uh you remember this battle
[Laughter]
yeah happily not no but why did you let
you relive the worst moments of your
life
in the uh i realized the the the um the
reason i brought up the
japan i i i forgot my own reason for
bringing it up
the tokyo uh opening ceremony was
the i remember i was watching it and i
as is predictable i guess you know the
olympics tend to be a spare no expense
moment for the
exhibiting country and um
and i'm watching this and they're using
a bunch of jrpg music including just
playing back the
the originals like with the fake
orchestra and i was like
well now that's very odd so i messaged a
few friends and i said you know why
why would they do that you know they
have like they've got the tokyo
philharmonic they've got
they've got no shortage of talented
musicians
um and there's composers everybody's
local like
broadly speaking uh like
what the hell it seems bizarre like it's
very and it would go back and forth
where some of it was live and some of it
wasn't
and um what i found out was it
apparently was all put together very
last second
because they had hired a japanese
composer to
write an original piece which is
typically what happens
because everyone was going oh this is so
cool japan is you know honoring its
its contribution to the world because i
mean jrpg is basically a category it's a
genre of music at this point i mean it's
it's like saying you know the morocco
spaghetti western or something yeah like
it
it it's a set of musical parameters that
have literally been defined that you can
adhere to or not and um and it was all
put together last second because
someone said oh you know apparently
apparently the
original composer they'd hired was sort
of found out to be
you know pretty terrible or something
like old bad tweets or something like
that and i just thought
you know that can dethrone you from the
olympics like jesus christ
and i went and looked and then it turned
out yeah this guy was actually
you're like this is culture god matter
that you looked you're like yeah they're
first oh there's this guy
no like this guy they said they said he
had um he had basically
insufficiently apologized for being a
bully as a kid and that made me think i
said every [ __ ] kid
is a bully or bullied as a kid like i'm
sorry but that seems like to to
decades later get you kicked off the
olympic scene stream but then you read
about what he did as a kid
and you're like i think this is where
the right to free association does kick
into play
because he apparently likes like eric
cartman
is actually a really good example
because apparently there was one kid who
he
psychologically tortured to the extent
of making him eat his own [ __ ]
uh like full-on psychopathic behavior
um and put out a statement like decades
later that said if i knew who that was
or where he was i promise i would
apologize but i don't know where he
lives or something like that
and then just went on about his life so
i was reading that i was like
well okay i guess i may be a little bit
on the side of the olympics committee on
this one
because scott tinnerman by the way that
was the that's exactly what i thought of
uh
it struck me as i couldn't believe the
extent
of the vile behavior and was like well
you know
because i do i do think that if someone
does something profoundly stupid or even
criminal
as a kid you want to live in a world
where people
are able to to um to rehabilitate
and the idea that you're a decision made
as a 14 year old
i want to live in a world where you know
you you are not damning
the next 60 years because of things that
you did when you
you're not even legally allowed to you
know make your own decisions like you
you you know there are always you know
extending
circumstances like yeah there are lines
exactly like you know
but most people are awful as kids
due to environmental concerns like
they've got you know like
like a lot of the worst bullies have
terrible parents you know very abusive
yeah
domestic and like there's a lot of
reasons why it's like if someone does
something [ __ ]
like oh perfect okay here's here's my
here's my example that i
that is hopefully not gonna sound
self-aggrandizing um but
like i got the absolute [ __ ] kicked out
of me
uh when i was in the seventh grade by a
kid he broke the the
bone called the orbit below your eye in
four places cracked open my sinus
gave me a concussion i fully blacked out
from the experience like it was
it was a severe assault like i literally
had to go to the hospital
my eyes swelled shut couldn't see out
this eye for several days
um it was a it was a full and i and i
had
real issues with confrontation for years
where i would get
instant heart palpitations if someone
even raised their voice at me
until basically college before that
finally started to go away
i feel like ptsd at that point right
like i mean
presumably something akin to that but
some some
some 13 year old version uh or or
my version i guess i would say because i
do think it's possible to happen at 13 i
shouldn't i shouldn't qualify it
but point being that kid went to juvie
for that um
and like he was expelled from school and
went and had to do a weekend in juvie
and if he talked to me
or asked his friends to talk to me for
like five years he went back
automatically
for like three months or something it's
like it was a severe sentence
but i don't want to live understand it
hold on as you understand it was that a
oops i i got away or was he intent
as you understand it was he willfully
trying to do that level of damage to you
or was it
i've known fights where people are like
i i you always saw the movie someone
break a bottle over someone's head
and it ended up killing the guy and so i
mean there's
there's things where people like i never
intended to do that it just this got
away from me or
hundred percent so now this kid we were
we were so this is this is the stupidity
of it we were in the lunch line in the
cafeteria in plain view of the entire
[ __ ] school
and justin turns the guy he says that
was han zimmer
and the guy's like well i was i was
you know the the nerdy scrawny kid you
know and
oddly enough punch he uh
he basically the thing i'll never forget
because i was so
like you know logical and i was [ __ ]
you know my heroes at that age were like
[ __ ] data and spock you know
and so uh he wanted to cut ahead of me
in line
in the [ __ ] lunch line and but there
were only like
three more people to the front we were
basically out of there so i was like
basically no [ __ ] off that's ridiculous
you is the
next 40 seconds of your time that on the
line
and he grabbed my hair and pushed me
down
and punched me close to 30 times in the
face i blacked out instantly i mean it
was a full concussion
immediately so i mean he he had to be
dragged off by
staff there was no crime of passion or
something i mean
he just the kid probably had [ __ ]
shitty parents who beat the [ __ ] out of
him you know i have no idea but like
he had he had massive amounts of
unconstrained rage and i just
was the random pedestrian who stepped in
front of the bull in that moment
said the wrong thing and it set him off
but my all reason i bring all this up
is because i don't want to live in a
world where his entire
future was completely [ __ ] forever
because of what he did to me that day
like i don't ever want to see him again
or interact with them
uh you know and and and uh like he you
hope that he gets rehabilitated
my hope was that he he found his way
into a life that doesn't
cause him to do [ __ ] like that and that
like if he
applies for a job and somebody looks at
that they go oh well you know 20 years
ago we saw you beat up
some kid in middle school you know
you know no thanks we don't take your
kindly around it like at some point i i
hope someone gives him a chance and that
he actually makes it worthwhile that
that's the whole point that was the
thing that pinged for me when i saw this
olympics thing where i thought
sure now what that guy did was you know
like
i got a rather severe version of
bullying but it is still fundamentally
like some kids are bullies and some kids
are stronger than others and this can
happen to be pretty damn strong
i don't want it to ruin his life even
though i sure it was pretty horrible
that would have to be the result the the
level that you're talking about of
rehabilitation
is a process so that is someone who said
something
did something wore something went to
something
whatever it was but they're just like i
don't know i'm not a person yet
and i'm figuring all of this stuff out
and for a moment in my
brief history on this planet i thought
that i could align myself with
x and then you realize through a process
that's not anything that i want to be
affiliated with i don't understand how
these people
whatever it is that brings you through
that process of going no longer do i
want to be associated with this widely
considered salacious thing
there there has to be other evidence
it's the people that go
you're pissed about that those are the
people that haven't done the work
it's the people that go my perfect
example is is adrock from
uh beastie boys when someone on the line
goes
you're sitting here you know petitioning
for women's rights and you're the guy
who wrote all i want is girls
and he was like look i'd rather be a
hypocrite than a bigot
and i'm like that's it i would rather
contradict my former self
blatantly and openly
than to continue to be the same person
that i was at 18 19.
i mean it telegraphs a good thing if
somebody is
being a hypocrite at some point like
when
when we see like in presidential debates
and stuff and people there's always this
obsession with
i look like i said 18 years ago i have
always
believed this i am rock steady there is
never
there's always a price paid on changing
one's mind on an issue
and there's a certain amount of
defeatism in political terms to say well
i
evolved on the subject and it's like and
people think they've caught you
in an old belief you know and it's like
you know
lest we remind you know when obama took
office he was
openly opposed to gay marriage for
example like
that was just not even 15 years ago
and like widely one of the most revered
among among
the left you know one of the one of the
most revered recent political figures
but like he wouldn't pass you know
that that test uh by today's standards
if he if we were to sort of take
everyone back in time to 2008
and so like the idea that that there
can't be
growth and can't be reevaluation and and
saying you know i was
i was wrong about that i i to me rock
steady lifelong consistency
is a sign of intellectual laziness in
most cases because it means you've never
questioned your biases
you've never questioned your assumptions
you've always assumed everything that i
learned
from 0 to 18 or 0 to 12 is apparently
everything i need to know about the
world
and like and how i will be forever the
concrete no new information could
possibly upend that i mean it's like
that's how outrageous we're all old
enough that we've witnessed enormous
cultural change just in our lifetimes
right
like how i hope so yeah various
like in terms of social justice issues
like yeah
it's it's already we're at the age and
you do get to decide when stuff's
happening
do you want to move with the times and
change and learn or do you want to be
the person complaining about young
people nowadays you know those are the
two options basically and it's kind of
like
well i think there's i i i don't know
that i would boil it down to just those
two
because of cultures yeah there's always
one nuance well but yeah plus cultures
can be wrong
like you can be you can like i mean if
you're a german in 1938 looking around
at this populist movement you could be
going
i don't i i'm a i'm a she better change
with the times i'm not going to change
my time
well exactly yeah that's the way i hate
these people now we
hate these people though okay
if the movement is towards hate and
exclusion
that's typically and historically a bad
movement we don't tend to celebrate the
people who are trying to withhold rights
from
people right or in any way
disenfranchised
where trends go love and inclusion
that's that's probably the rail that you
want to be on
yeah it's true but it goes by the way
for any argument
i hate these people it's like yo you're
on the wrong side of this man
because you can never ever ever ever
ever ever ever
out hate someone but it's never that
that's the thing it's
it's it's not you need to hate these
people
in such it's it's that but in veiled
terms it's
all your life's problems are being
caused by these people and if you're
someone who genuinely has
problems that's a seductive argument you
know germany post-world war one was an
economic catastrophe
it was an easily co-opted situation of
you know all you people there's there's
actually someone to blame
for this and if you're sitting there
with those you know these famous photos
of people taking wheelbarrows full of
cash
to burn because it's more valuable as
fuel than it is as
money uh then you know if somebody says
i happen to know the solution you know
10 more love
uh than uh i full circle it's beautiful
i i do think that that is a seductive
thing that's why that's why i
i i um i think that
the we're at it we're at a very
challenging and difficult moment um
in american politics right now because i
i i as someone who has family
and friends across the political
spectrum like the problem is the venn
diagrams get really difficult because
yes of course you know there's no
defense of trump
but there are a lot of people that were
sold his kind of populist protectionist
agenda
that i don't believe are bigots and
racists and i think that the
the conflation of trump supporter equals
bigot and racist i'm like i think that
there's a lot of factory workers
look this is why andrew yang was tamiya
was a very
uh compelling potential guy to st
to win those people across party lines
because he was saying i
get you i see your problem all you you
know
millions of truckers looking at
self-driving cars and going
i got a real problem on my hands like
that like my job is
very soon going to be fully automated
out of existence and like
those are a lot of folks that that felt
spoken to
by trump for better or worse i i again i
i think that i think that
you know there's probably plenty of
bigoted [ __ ] who you know were all
too happy to go along
and i would never deny that but i think
it's just it's when we oversimplify it
uh it's to our own peril because again a
lot of these things you look like
in the 30s too you know if you if you
were if you were
you know supported that fella you were
doing so
either because you agreed with what you
were saying or because you were
willfully ignoring what he was saying
like yeah there wasn't like oh i had no
idea really these things oh no
like no one was shocked by any of that
no so it's kind of like
absolutely no i think that willfully
ignoring is an absolutely true thing
there's a lot of people that hated him
voted for him
they voted for people responsible for
that but they felt that and you could
precise them for the action well but i i
i can i i did not vote this way but i
can empathize with that position because
i think they're saying
here's a guy who's gonna try what he
says is he's trying to
he's trying to uh fight to keep my job
and he's got you know
the the good old homeland uh folks
in in mind and and i i wouldn't get i
wouldn't
you know i wouldn't introduce my
daughter to this [ __ ] [ __ ] like
you saw
there's a lot of republicans that felt
that way what's the blazing saddles
quote good
honest hard-working people
you know idiots
yeah i mean it's i i really i felt bad
for a lot of those folks you know
because i thought they felt they felt
like they they had to vote for an option
that they that they hated
um and the sad thing was obviously it's
a con job he didn't give a [ __ ] about
trump served only himself so like i felt
those people were fleeced but i
do empathize with them having been
victims of i can't
ties with the source of it i can also
criticize them for being
so easily con though for sure like it's
it's uh
isn't that blaming the victim of a sort
i mean
if someone weren't the victim of his
policies they weren't the victim of his
but the victim of a con
i'm talking about the first election i i
it becomes a very different matter
in his re-election and he lost so but i
i do i do think that his first election
you know he's to most people he's that
guy from the apprentice you know like
they just don't follow this stuff uh
they don't follow his twitter
they don't follow i think you are right
to say that most of the blame lies with
the liar rather than the white two i
think that's i think that's fair that's
what i think fundamentally all i'm
saying
yeah yeah i think some of the blame goes
to the person being lied to as well we
all
we're responsible for our actions even
if they're i think it's kind of like
fool me once shame on you fool me twice
shame on me kind of a thing like i think
i i just don't see how you could
possibly ever blame somebody
uh who's been lied to
for having been tricked but once
it's demonstrated and they don't care
we're in a different situation
fundamentally yeah
yeah i guess i guess i'm on the i'm on a
slightly yeah i guess
i agree with you in the broad strokes
but i do think there's i think we're all
responsible for all our actions even if
we take them
stupidly like i think even if you can i
certainly don't disagree with that
yeah i mean so there's still
responsibility though that would be my
wow this this got it's got an
interesting place
if there is an opportunity for
authorship or agency into a thing
and someone says here are the keys to
this car
now we want you to know that
the steering is out of alignment the
brakes are a little dodgy
um the carburetor is about to explode
and there's no gas
if i go okay and i get into the car
and either the car falls apart i hit
another person
it stops working i can't get out and
blame
the car i willfully
knowledgeably looked at that or
if no one told me anything about the car
i am still responsible
when someone hands me the keys to go
i need to know certain things about this
car is it in working condition
it is on to me because i am making the
active choice
to operate something that can give me
transportation
that can grant me the needs that i have
or or the desires at least
or could also potentially harm somebody
else
i think there's a societal
responsibility we need to become more
comfortable with criticism
just generally yeah dude personal life
could not agree more with that
culture like like i think it's
absolutely okay to hold someone
accountable or criticize them
and we i think we too quickly jump to
the idea that criticizing someone
is punishing someone or attacking
someone you know
like just austin said it's damning for
the rest of your life
or that it's nothing you should often
just it's like
like like it's it's you know if you even
even the example of the
the i don't know the case so i i don't
know the specifics of this but
the thing you said about the composer at
the olympics like that guy's
still working he still has a life he's
still he just
was that one opportunity for the best
job in the world
was unavailable to him because he was a
bit of an [ __ ] once
um or a lot of was gonna say or a sort
of psychopath
right i have no idea the guy you're
talking about the point is there's a
there's a gradation right like that
guy's life has not been ruined
by something he did as a kid it's been
influenced and that's a there's a
difference i think we jump very quickly
to the binary thing of
this person's being criticized publicly
therefore their life is over they've
been canceled this is the worst crime
that could be committed against another
human being
and that's that's a big jump whereas
actually yeah sure that's a fair
criticize absolutely it's a absolutely
fine thing
and that there are consequences like
like when i mentioned
the the kid the my my childhood bully
for example
like if he'd applied to 10 jobs and
three of them
said you know we you've gotta
you've got like jail time on your record
and like we're that's not
we're not comfortable hiring you sorry
like i do believe that's within their
right to like they shouldn't be
forced uh but i hope that of those tens
not all came to that conclusion that's
my point yeah
and that's that's what we generally see
with people who are quote unquote
cancelled or people who
you know like they still have you know
they can still get jobs like they can
still
they can still go on with their lives
it's always an opportunity to turn it
around
yeah and i think that we as a society
this is something we're processing
because to be fair
this is the first time in human history
where global accountability is actually
a thing we have to deal with
right so of course it's going to be a
weird challenge and we're going to we're
not going to get all the rules of that
right
immediately i think what i i think for
the issue i have uh is interesting it's
actually
these two threads actually connect in
that way insofar as i think troy the
point you were making about the car with
regard to like a trump voter
is that they did insufficient due
diligence they basically didn't ask
questions about the car
and then they took it my and i and i
think that's a perfectly valid argument
like but they were not
hold on i also want to be clear there it
wasn't like
here's the car whatever you want to
figure out is there the car was
blatantly advertising
all of its flaws blatantly widely there
was smoke coming out of the car
yeah i think that that is a perfectly
valid criticism of like
the the uninformed or the the
the kind of failure to engage in due
diligence as a voter uh
and i and you know i also think it's a
reality that most people don't
they just don't do that and and also
when people are acting out of fear
um and they they they make you know
uninformed decisions or they make uh
decisions they probably otherwise so i
guess i'm this and that that
that was a huge problem it's like i
think you are either one of these two
things you're either the worst person to
me for this reason or you're the worst
person to me for this reason
and that that is the the problem the
main issue that this
world has right now speaking of global
accountability is you do have this rise
of global accountability
plus you have zero discourse and that
the only way that those two that's
exactly where i was that's exactly
this course that's where i was sort of
going with that too is is that you know
i think your point is well made
on the car um um even though i do
empathize with people who are acting out
of fear because they are afraid
like i don't wanna i don't wanna lose
sight of the fact that like
just because every neuroscientist on the
planet can explain to you that that is
not your rational faculties are fully
not working
if you are in total fear you just want
to alleviate your fear so if you're
voting based on fear
you're not making a rational decision
and that's how you get you know a
candidate
and then a president like that and i i
empathize with it even if i think it's
[ __ ] tragic but the but that's that's
a good qualifier too is
is criticism must be administered with
empathy not devoid of it
well it's also the question of what's
the point of the what's the point of the
criticism is it to make someone better
or to make them worse
that's the problem i have with the
global accountability thing we've got
going on is that
is that you know twitter is so easily a
situation where
no context whatsoever can lead to a
situation where you have somebody who's
rarely interacts with more than 20
people on a day-to-day basis suddenly
has tens of thousands of people calling
them
the worst thing ever and i'm like it's
not criticism we're not condemnation
we're not equipped to deal with that
like it's one even if even if they said
the worst thing ever
they can have potentially thousands of
people coming taking the task for it
when five seconds earlier it was like
them and five friends are interacting
online or whatever and i just to me it's
it's a it's a volatile
it's a volatile environment that i that
i think yeah we
it is it is not encouraged discourse it
does definitely encourage
yelling um which is a shame because i do
think that the way that it interconnects
people is
broadly speaking unbelievably incredible
i mean the number of people that i've
met
because of these these tools that i
would not have in a prior
chapter of human history is on it's
probably the majority of people that
i've i mean i
think it's true for both of you and
alana
um like the pre-internet i don't know
how we would have met
you know like so it's like i i i
i gary would have introduced us
but he said carrie and i was like now
that's a curious hypothesis
um uh true fair point so yeah it's one
of those that i i feel like
my my biggest takeaway of all this is
that i feel like we're in this kind of
we're in this like awkward teenage
transition state as a civilization right
now
where we it's like it's like when a kid
goes through a growth spurt and they
don't know how to really use their legs
because they're suddenly like six inches
taller than they were a few months ago
and they just are awkward like everyone
has known or was that lanky
kid that yeah that that yeah and i was
like
like yeah and like i feel like that's
kind of where we are right now where
we fling about and we accidentally knock
over a giant china case and it destroys
everything and we're like oh [ __ ]
because we're still
this technology like there's a great um
there's a great quote from einstein he
was referring to nuclear power but he
says
our chief problem is a perfection of
means but a confusion of aims
we're basically we're we
we don't have clarity and wisdom with
which to to use
world endingly powerful technology do
you know what do you know what i
i like there's um oh god what's he
saying i'm gonna have to look out i
think there's a guy called
rowan coleman here we go jesus jesus
christ
uh jesus h christ um most people don't
know that
[Laughter]
um the uh the was gonna say
uh the there's a guy called i think
rowan coleman who's a
youtuber makes like star trek videos and
i love star trek obviously
and i thought he said something very
profound about star trek i found really
interesting as a way of look
reappraising star trek which is
jumping off what you're saying which is
star trek is one of the only sci-fi
universes
that optimistically assumes that
humanity's
um ethics and morality will evolve at
the same pace as their technology
and that's the thing that kind of sets
it apart and is interesting
is the idea that that we move on as a
culture and we learn all this new
technology
but that we also evolve as a species at
the same pace and are able to do that in
a positive
way most sci-fi assumes that you know
we're basically going to be the same in
200 years
like the expansion spaceships have you
watched the expanse like it it's
i need to get to i've tried to watch
that pilot a couple of times and i've
been told you have to push past the
pilot that's
people always say that i i will get to
it i think it's perfection i think it's
so
goddamn excellent and it is exactly as
you said it is
humans behaving incredibly realistically
uh
because i think that's where star trek i
love the optimism of star trek but i
think it's optimism to the point of
unrealism like
humans the human beings today are
fundamentally the same instincts we're
driven by the same primal
urges and all that kind of stuff as the
humans of the renaissance and that's the
that's
this the captain picard is closer to us
today than
leonardo da vinci is to us today like by
a measure of time
like i don't think that now you said
kept pace with the evolution of
technology which i suppose
would imply an exponential curve but and
that's the that's what makes it
fantastical right because that's not
what's happened historically i think
biologically that that's probably
impossible unless we just cease to be
human
uh i meant if i meant evolve in the uh
ethics no i know
but no but the physiological one but yes
i take a point but they're the same
thing
they're the same thing our brains are
wired for survival
on the savannahs of africa and the fact
that humanity migrated out of africa
and and and built things all over the
planet built societies built
cultivated thousands of languages and
religions and we're not
programmed in a core way to do all that
it's astonishing i mean as as
as modern physicists are fond of
pointing out the fact that we can even
begin to comprehend something as
unintuitive as quantum mechanics when it
has
no analog in our lived day-to-day
experience is truly an insane
statement about the capacity of the
human brain because it has zero
evolutionary benefit whatsoever
or music right like well music actually
i'm not so sure that's the case
because music most certainly predates
language uh
and uh for sure but it's still a
completely human invention right it
doesn't music
requires no i don't agree with that
either i wouldn't say it like
song things would you argue well it
depends on how you define music you know
most
modern definitions would say something
along the lines of music is simply
organized sound
um and right but that requires an
organizer
but almost every animal that vocalizes
is doing that
that's a really interesting point i'm
not thought of that would you say that
like a painting
i'm underestimating birds i think
i mean there's a lot of complexity and
there are composers like famously a
a french composer um uh from the mid
20th century named meseon who
who became so obsessed and so
knowledgeable about birds and he
he transcribed so many bird songs that
you know he could clock a species you
know male female etc off of like a split
second a bird song
because he just knew their their calls
so well and he incorporated it into his
music
in various ways essentially essentially
quoting them
um and the first sample right
dude i just dropped this bad ass bird
i'm trying to think uh there are there
are funny like tick tock accounts of
people that that uh transcribe like
birds and
seals and stuff and then emulate them on
their instruments and it puts the
it shows like footage of the bird and
then they the transcribed sheet music
and then shifts over to the person on
like an oboe trying to recreate it
exactly
and some of them are pretty amazing
because seals in particular
sound like ring-modulated analog synths
because they're like
and they have all these sounds that are
just bizarre that you wouldn't realize
is coming out of
essentially a vocal cord or whatever i
actually don't know how they vocalize
but
in any case yeah that to me music this
is why i
say one of my little one of my little
catch phrases is that um
all almost every art is an
is emblematic of the amazing capacity of
human creativity
because they are fundamentally
artificial inventions but music is the
art we discovered
uh it's not the one we invented that's a
that's a that's a kind of
it's a little bit of a hallmark card
thing because obviously all the rules of
music
like if an alien here's here's here's
the here's the thought experiment if we
encountered an
extra solar civilization
music the you know the this
uh sorry this a440 to a880 that not that
this piano is actually in tune to those
exactly what is that
but like a440 to aa80
um there's nothing inaccessible about
about that to any civilization in the
world now
the specific way well it
but but that's just vibration of a
medium like and
even space has dust in it like vibration
is detectable in space that's why they
say oh
we just heard what a black hole sounds
like now the medium is such that the
pitch is like 90 octaves below anything
we could ever possibly
the oscillations are like the size of
the earth you know i mean the the
the the the but it is an
oscillation that's all pitch is um in
fact there's a
fantastic demonstration of this in the
in adam neely's youtube channel
where he takes a sample playing
like a c and he's like a low i think i
can't remember what note it is but he
plays
a note that's not a 440. and then in
just using a sampler
he just speeds it up so that that note
is repeating 440 times per second
and it becomes an a we cannot not hear
it as an a because that's
the way he puts in the video is so
beautifully succinctly goes all pitch is
is a thing happening a certain number of
times per second and no matter what that
source sound is you repeat it 440 times
per second
it's gonna sound approximately like that
pitch not necessarily the color of a
piano though obviously
and um so any species
in the world these are physics that are
just
endemic to the universe as we like there
is
acoustical physics are just natural part
of reality so
the question is i think play is another
i think if you're in engaging with some
a species with the intellectual capacity
to be
interacting with you by definition they
would have had to have
uh form social groups uh
you know learned things which means
probably well though definitely play has
to be a part of their history so play
as a concept the idea of like
experimental play
right would also be there well i think
that does presume
that does anthropomorphize a little bit
though because like what if a species
evolved
in a like an ant like capacity that's
pure hive mind
and but you know for a billion years
eventually developed this kind of
rachni like ability to leave their
planet without a spaceship like we could
encounter
an alien civilization that has no
corollary to being a social species
i wouldn't be surprised if what you're
saying is is
you know a reasonable assumption but i
also think you're right now i'm making
an assumption that any
anything that would be in that position
of intelligence to do that task would be
a social species but you're right that's
also an assumption but the thing that
tantalizes me is the idea that maybe
there's forms of intelligence that we
just don't even
like we have you know hive intelligence
and we've got individual intelligence
but maybe there's
maybe that's two out of 10 000
categories and we just because nothing
on earth evolved that way we can't
we have nothing to compare it with you
know all of our science is basically
comparative
so we're you know we're looking at what
depends on yeah
like there's there's different schools
of thought right because there's the
convergence theory as well there's the
idea that
actually there are basic there are a
limited number of forms
if you look at like dolphins and sharks
is the obvious example like
basically the same animal completely
different evolutionary paths yeah like
bats and birds
just yeah maybe there are optimal
solutions to these problems well
maybe we're going to go into the
universe and find a lot of sharks it
could be that yeah
star trek aliens where they're basically
humans but with you know
facial makeup maybe that's not so funny
less small makeup
is the reality of it it's true like grab
what are the consistency you know
nitrogen oxygen
you know uh hydrogen helium like
earth and the living forms on it are
made of the most abundantly
generic [ __ ] in the universe and gravity
you know different planets are going to
have different forms of gravity but even
our solar system
has a few planets venus and mars
that are pretty similar size and makeup
broadly speaking to us
with different environmental it's like
the idea that you know earth-like
planets with
earth-like uh conditions you're right
could we find sharks
we'd find sharks on bats on earth-like
planets but we'd find completely
different forms
on literally any other kind of thing i'm
not even i don't even think i'm saying
anything that you could possibly say i'm
right
i'm just saying it doesn't i think we've
solved this i think we've solved this i
think the drake equation i think
we've got it yeah we're gonna call up on
those billionaires get a spaceship and
mount a mission next week to be great
i just want to imagine all of the people
listening right now
at some point i think there's very few
at this point
did we get high there's some people
right now that
i'm not the only one who's not actually
drinking coffee yeah
doesn't this doesn't this show have that
energy most episodes like the kind of
like
for me this show is like the the 12
o'clock you've just been to a bar with
friends you're back at someone's place
you're having just a rambling
conversation
these are the conversations i live for
man
it's so funny austin and i will call
each other and be like hey man what's
going on he's like
so anyway existentialism and i know you
know
it's not even that it's not even what's
going on it's hey i have a very specific
question for you
like simple questions simple answer one
hour later
never ask the question uh we're just on
twitter
every conversation there's never a wrap
up it's always like
uh i have to hang up the phone now
something
something is happening that's that's
precluding us it's true you know what we
should
do in this conversation you know how
like zoom accounts will have like the
timer that after 40 minutes it just cuts
you off we should just install like a
kill switch
on the phone you know at 60 minutes it
just
it just goes because otherwise you know
we'll never the kill switch is this
intro the show because we got to get out
of here it's true
you're the host austin's the host all
right well
hi please carry on austin seriously
i know well this was play watch listen
uh uh sans our
host our real host who is
maybe in undisclosed locations uh
somewhere
she's she's definitely having some kind
of
nathan drake style gallivanting about
the world it would seem
so uh uh x
uh like sans alana uh that's
wait i have to do it that way that's
mike bithell gaming i shoot
game designer that's troy baker game
actor
i'm austin game composer all of us
limited by our medium and incapable of
anything outside of games
we are landlocked at this point yeah and
uh
that was today's show about which i have
no idea the title of this episode is
going to be
alana is gone and this is what happens
when she's not here yeah medicine
in alana's stat yeah we we ramble in
alana's absence
it's true unsupervised i did like the
last time it was called
mike troy and austin interview each
other this is what she called it last
time we did this
you're a better writer than that alana
come on you can do this along and we
believe in you